They have to stay with the person that they applied with. This
ensures this is for a true romantic purpose and not for a scam.
And this needs to be heavily enforced by ICE agents. We're hiring
more ice agents. Maybe Pokémon can
dude. This is uh Oh, no. This is Oh, this is H1Bs. Technically,
if you try to lead this person, you get deported. Keep this person.
We'll deport you.
Keep writing the code. Keep writing the coat sing or you're getting
deported. Okay, you're back to Mumbai.
The legal mindset video really quickly. I've been told that legal
mindset may have cracked again. He's having yet another mental
break. Is this true, guys? Legal mindset mental breakdown part
two. Is it possible that we could have a part two here? Get the
out of here. Part two of the legal mindset mental breakdown.
Make America breed again. Fast facts.
Fast facts. Make America breed again. What? What? What? >> Make
Americans breed again. Today we're going to talk about an American
breeding visa that can fix the birth rate crisis and bring things
back from the brink in America and sol.
That's just called regular immigration from the third world,
brother.
You bring people in from the third world, they have like 12 kids.
That's just that's just bring them in from the third world. Okay,
hold on. Is he going to Is he going to propose that you only
import hotties from other countries? Dude, that is actually that
is dangerously close to funny and based. Okay, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait. Is this It might be the unironic Alex
Stein big booty Latina meme. Yeah, if you're an eight out of
10 from any country, you get an automatic visa into the States.
It is kind of based. It would only be based from like an actual
trad person who is just like we need people. We need beautiful
people here to create a beautiful like country. All right. But
this guy th this guy is just a degenerate who doesn't like looking
at ugly women
up. Okay. Also many of the issues that are plaguing the country.
Of course it's a legal mindset. We teach you to be your own judge.
I'm Dude, this is the only way the only way to fix the incel
problem in America is to make the gender ratio 2:1. Okay? We
need two women for every one man. We need these women to be desperate
for men's attention. >> Andrew Esquire, American attorney
living over here in Asia. And I hope all of you are having a
wonderful day. This is of course the fastfax version, which is
the quick and dirty version of the latest in legal news. If you
like this, make sure you like the video and comment below. Let's
get into the >> I'll take all the Brits. Uh, no, no, no,
no. There's no, trust me, Britain. Britain, not by
principle, but by effect, will be excluded from this policy.
Okay. >> Breeding visa. I have a PowerPoint for you guys
to enjoy here. Uh, make Americans breed again. Okay. What's the
problem? The problem is America, no babies. No babies. It's a
societal problem. It's a problem that is not just
>> Do you think he understands the problem? Do you think
he understands that like the birth rate going down is because
of persistent urbanization and that the countries that he loves
most are actually most affected by this and have like the worst
birth rate? crisises crisis crisis crisises crisis crisis >> America
it's many developing countries uh it's many other countries that
have very very similar problems where their birth rates are dropping
fast and this is a chronic problem for any country because when
you have this you're going to have problems in the future with
your economy with your society it
yeah
literally urbanization
not really no koko no People say that that is not what it is.
Um that people say that but that is only a product of modern
living. People who are the most
like underprivileged people who are the most like impoverished
have the most kids. Like this is pretty consistent. There's like
something about there's something about middle class white people
where they don't want to have kids unless they're they feel financially
like fulfilled. But that's mostly just like they they don't want
to have kids cuz they don't want to have kids. It would be like
hard. That'd be like a real burden. I think that's mostly it.
>> A massive massive risk. So the question is how do you
turn this around? And we're looking for solutions to turn this
around and make Americans have families again. Uh so solution,
right? And there's a male and female solution here, right? Big
for the ladies and for the men. Well, there's a lot of very attractive
uh foreign men and women and there are American >> Oh,
hold on. Hold on. I This is a very common uh a very common like
Japanese
theme. Unironically, this is a very common Japanese name now.
Thanks to Shinszo AB. All right. They're like, "Oh, the birth
rate is going down." So, we've actually like assigned partners.
This is like the start of every Japanese. Not even joking. This
guy was like off and he was like, "Hold on. I'm going to I'm
going to introduce this idea to my audience as a thing we should
do in America." Okay.
Or anime. No, no, no, no. It's like I'm saying an anime. No,
no, no, no. This is like This is like a thing.
It's like the birth rate's dropping. We're gonna introduce this
like force breeding program. There's so many fetishes that he
is incorporating into this video at the same time. This is some
wild stuff. >> Women and American men that would love to
go and uh have well some breeding opportunities uh opened up
to them uh here today. So, we've got, you know, whether you're
interested in any flavor of dude, we've got that here. Same for
the guys. We've got, you know, we've got the Latin flavor, we've
got Easter
Question. Hey, Mr. Legal Mindset, sir. Question. What prevents
the hotties from just each other? Why would they go for any of
your audience members? Excuse me. Question. Why don't the hotties
just [__] each other? Why would they [__]
you instead of each other?
Question. >> In Europe, we've got Asia. A lot of places
that you can go to explore these new possible breeding opportunities.
Now, before you think this is crazy, you're like, Andrew, this
is absolutely nuts, right? This is This is wild. Well, no. Japan
is already doing this. Japan
>> I just want to I just want to point out
real quick. This this is the guy a bunch of like the O 20,000
like followers follow and take seriously on legal issues. Okay,
that's who this guy is. This guy is taken very seriously by drama
people. Uh the lawyer the the YouTube lawyer said I was correct.
The YouTube lawyer says Ethan Klein is totally in the right in
every possible way. The YouTube lawyer said this. The YouTube
lawyer also well I don't want to hate on legal mindset too much
because he does seem to with Destiny which is pretty funny but
I should probably go over that stuff too. Didn't him and Destiny
get into a fight. Destiny accused him of being like minded by
Lauren de Laguna. Everybody who doesn't like me is mind controlled
by this one.
Oh my god. Crazy stuff. Anyway, sorry. We keep going. already
has a visa for future creation of an individual. Doesn't that
sound lovely? Doesn't that sound cute? Future creation of an
individual, a spouse or child of a future creation individual.
So, they're already doing this up to 2 years. You're allowed
to come to Japan. You're allowed to go there. Uh, and you're
supposed to be at the same time job hunting, looking for uh some
sort of entrepreneurial job or engaging in some sort of other
activity, right? So, you're doing something. You're not doing
nothing there. You're not idle. You're not homeless, etc., right?
And you have to have certain level of education, right? And you
have to be able to support yourself. There has to be money to
support them. Now, Japan's program is not perfect. Japan's program
does have its flaws. And America, like with California rules,
can do everything better. We're taking over their version. We're
making it better. And Japan, once again, very advanced country,
does a lot of things right, but America can do it better. So,
let's tell you how I would plan on doing this. And by the way,
Americans want this.
Yeah, Lauren de Laguna.
Destiny responded to Lauren De Laguna's reply to my clip of when
Destiny made that claim. Oh, substance after this video. Remind
me, we should go over a couple of your tweets cuz I also saw
one of your tweets from today or yesterday. That is actually
funny and I do want to go over it. It's just like
not really related drama, but it's just funny. >> We've
seen with Asma Gold over here, right? Thirsty for Gran. We've
seen this with uh people thirsty for the uh Korean male celebs
over here. So, the American thirst is real.
This is um oh man,
this is very funny because one thing you can do to grift for
people is you you like basically
demonize some group of people or you you come up with a solution
for a different group of people. Okay, you can demonize like
an out group or for the in-group, you come up with a solution
that's like supposed to work for them, but like you just lie.
So Trump was like, "Oh guys, I'm totally going to bring factories
back. I'm going to bring factories back. You're all going to
get your jobs back." And now Legal Mindset has found the these
So those people were economically disenfranchised by free trade
policies, by changing economic conditions. Okay. Now Legal Mindset's
audience has been disenfranchised. And he's like, "Guys, I can
bring you hotties in from other countries and they'll [__]
you." Okay. They won't find you disgusting because they're from
other countries. What? I don't know. I don't know, man. I don't
know. That seems pretty crazy. Are you also going to give these
hotties labbotoies? Is that a requirement? Okay. You can come
in to breed or be bred, but you have to have a labbotomy. So,
you can't you have to be like actually medically blinded so that
you can't see the people from you. All right.
You can come to America, but you have to accept we take your
eyes. Okay. 100%.
This is absolutely something that Americans are clamoring for.
So, here's the requirements. Here's my plan. Once again, this
is the legal mindset breeding visa. I'm doing not as an April
Fool's joke. This is a very real thing and will very much fix
this. I've gone through these criteria. And as somebody who's
lived abroad, who's dealt with dozens and dozens and dozens of
different visa applications and visa types, this is something
that's very much in my experience, my personal experience of
having to deal with visas. These requirements will 100% work.
The admins can pretty much copy paste these and they will work
off the
peace talk. What would your breeding requirements be? Uh, dude,
I I just can't I can't explain enough
that the lack of breeding doesn't have to do with a lack of Okay,
it's just not true. People will tell you that, oh, kids aren't
having these days. That's a different problem than people not
having kids. Lots of people in committed relationships are having
one kid at most. Guess what? Having one kid, that's not replacement
level breeding. That's not replacement level like anything. Okay?
That's two people coming together creating one offspring. That's
your country dying. Okay? There's absolutely nothing to do it's
nothing to do with the lack of it's birth control and like economic
prosperity, urbanization. You don't need So when you were on
a farm and you were married, you had 12 kids because you needed
those 12 kids to help you run the farm. Okay, that's what you
needed. Now, if you live in the city, 12 kids, that's a headache.
Ain't nobody got room for 12 kids in their house. You got to
be rich as Okay. Yeah. One. So, you needed more kids
when you were when you had a farm. You needed more kids. That's
what it is. Okay. when you or when you just lived anywhere in
the country, when you had like a job that that you could use
the free labor from your kids, okay,
is how tons of people had tons of kids for a long time and then
they'd go to the cities and they'd like work in the cities. All
right, also those kids would die. There was a little bit of an
infant mortality thing, but like 12 is just high. You would you
would just have like five or six kids, four to six kids was like
very very very normal, right? And yeah, so there's I guess the
third thing would be in as far as the the entertainment goes
would be you have like a very frictionless life right now. You
don't have to work very hard to do anything. Okay. And honestly,
raising kids is hard. How can you how can you go your whole life
live on social media, live with like apps delivering your every
whim to you at the drop of a hat and then go, "Yeah, I want the
work of raising a kid actually. Yeah, I want to raise a kid.
That seems like I, you know, I'd really enjoy doing that."
Really? No man, that sounds like a lot of work
base. So, let's just go over here and say, okay, what are the
eligible countries? Well, countries which do not pose a security
risk. So, hello CIA. How about you wake up? You stop, you know,
doing crazy stuff, woke stuff. You stop MK Ultraing people and
you know, you go and you actually collect facts on countries.
So, you go and say which >> Oh, hold on. Oh, yeah. Evil
Johnny Bravo. I just said all of this. That's a lot. But yeah,
I just said all this.
Yeah, exact. Oh yeah, exactly. There you
Yeah, we Yep. Yep. 100%. >> Are posing security risks which
are not. So obviously we don't want anywhere where people are
at danger or being trafficked. So that's the second one. You
do these countries do not engage in trafficking. Human trafficking
is an absolute evil and anyone caught engaging in human trafficking
should be jailed and thrown away for a very very very long time.
Human trafficking is absolutely evil. So,
okay.
[laughter]
I feel like it's a little weird when he goes to all the countries
where people aren't necessarily like you I think you still call
it trafficking potentially when you're you do call it trafficking
still. He goes to a lot of countries that are like women are
very high risk of being trafficked. Okay. For a guy who says
trafficking is evil. He goes to countries with a intention to
like a bunch of Yeah. He goes to a bunch of countries with intention,
a lot of human trafficking. Okay, that's very strange. Very concerning
pattern.
>> These things should be shut down right away. Next, this
is for the breeding applicants. So, we only need fit people in
the country. We do not need overweight people. One of the problems
in America is, and I just came back, is people are still overweight.
A lot of people are still overweight. That's not okay. We need
a health and fitness test, a low BMI. Now, I know some people
are going to say, "This is just to get in attractive people."
Well, these things tend to be correlated, right? Attractiveness
tends to be correlated with better fitness, better health. So,
yes, you've got to get fit. You've got to get in shape. If you're
not in shape, it's not going to work. I like that he's created
this to seem like regimented and like non-discriminatory. Okay.
I
Okay, maybe. Maybe standard education, at least high school.
It's like this is totally flexible depending on how low your
BMI is. Like how hot you are. If you're really hot, you could
be a okay. I don't care. You're you're you know you're medically
brain dead. I don't care. Are you a 10 out of 10? Come over here.
We can breathe you. We'll figure it out. We got science here.
We got really great hospitals. All right. We'll figure it out.
>> You have to have a standard education.
I'm saying at least high school. By high school, you've learned
a lot of the important things for your life. You've learned the
basic skills. You've learned math, you've got English, you got
science, you've got all the bedrock that you need to go forward.
There isn't really anything that is necessary in university or
can't be dealt with by technical training or apprenticeship.
And there's a lot of Americans that don't want to go to university
now because it's essentially propaganda and they want to go work
or they want to do something like cyber security with my friend
Ryan's cyber security course at Elevate Cyber. I'll put a link
to that in the
description below. With that, Oh, also we need to what do we
need to do? We need to close the Twitch stream. We're going to
go to kick only, guys. Kick only for the rest of the stream.
Okay.
Headed over there right now.
Oh my god, dude. Oh, hold on. Um Todd Bronson made me I I asked
him for a Santa guy. Okay, hold on a second. But he he decided
to make a Santa guy. Okay, like a Santa avatar, but he made it
for me being tired. So, quick spoiler on that. Just give me a
second. I'm going to put it on here. >> People are not
wanting to go to actual university. They're wanting to go into
some sort of training. They're wanting to go to work. And that's
fine. Let's let them do that and let's let them go outside uh
and find people who are also very similar to them and have the
same similar levels. Maybe they've gone out and become YouTubers.
Who knows? Uh and the next is a verbal English fluency test.
They need to be at least conversational. This is important, right?
We don't we don't want people over here that don't have verbal
English. I know there's issues with people being dyslexic and
we have to be consider that for writing, but your verbal skills
need to be on point. You need to be able to communicate. You
will not be able to have a deep meaningful relationship with
somebody, man or woman, it doesn't matter. Uh you're not going
to be able to have a deep meaningful relationship unless you
have a English fluency and the ability to converse. That is entirely
important to fall deeply in love with somebody or have a relationship
that lasts. And that's what this program is about. This is not
about coming in for a quick green card. This is not about any
sort of exploitation. This is about finding people that are going
to come over to America, create American babies, create American
families, and stay with their partner. That's the important thing.
Requirements for the American breeder. That's the American applicant,
right? So, I'm putting them that in that category. So, there's
the foreign breeding applicant.
>> Proud of the eyes. What the [__] What the
[__]
[laughter] This is accurate right now, but Jesus Christ, it's
terrifying. Holy [__]
It's like my what my brain sees right now. This my my brain is
my brain has these eyes. Okay, >> there's the American.
The requirements for the American host, right? So, the American
host has to have sufficient income to support the breeder at
least 100K. Uh, that's that's necessary. And has paid for all
existing dependent. >> Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait. This is just mail orderer brides with extra
steps, isn't it? This is like legally sanctioned, US sanctioned
mail order brides is what this is. Never mind. This is already
a thing. He's just he's just describing mail order brides. >> Children,
right? So, you have to have everything paid for. So, if you have
any children that are not fully taken care of and paid for, sorry,
you can't you can't do it. >> I believe he would make this
listen. Requirements for breeding applicant, requirements for
American host, has sufficient income to support the breeder.
No, it should be the the the bread. Okay, the bread support the
bread brackets the Okay, I >> it's just not you're not
able to qualify for the program. So, you have to have that sufficient
money. Next, you have to have a clean criminal record. Okay,
so if you have a criminal record where you're out there doing
bad things, whatever, not going to work. And next, you have to
have traveled to the country physically to meet the breeding.
Guys, my lifestyle wouldn't be weird at all if the American government
sanctioned it. What if the American government actually just
made my lifestyle like a norm and tried to like sanction it and
say this was good? Then nobody could call me a weirdo. Nobody
could call me a tourist. If the American government says it's
okay, then my lifestyle is totally good. [music] Oh my >> To
meet the person you're going to breed with and have kids with.
So whether you're a man or woman, you got to go out there, you
got to get on a plane, and you got to meet this person, right?
You cannot stay in America and do mail order stuff. That's exploitative.
That's wrong. You're not actually in love with that person, right?
That's a scam. None of that. Right? You've got to go physically
there, meet them. You got to have photos. You have to have proof
that you're in love with this person. You got to show them messages.
You got to show them backup.
Okay, never mind. Wait, hold on. Hold on. Now he's just shifted
to Has he just created like Oh, what is it? Oh, it's a sugar
the sugar daddy website. What is it called? What's the sugar
daddy website?
Uh, it's got like a really innocuous name that's not totally
on the
It's like, you know what it is, but it's got a different name.
Why can't I remember it? That's what he's created here, right?
Oh, go over there and then you have to prove that you have the
money. Not Ashley Madison. No, that's not the Sugar Daddy website.
What? What? Seeking arrangement. Yes, he's just creating seeking
arrangement. Okay. based. No marrying your cousin. None of this
scam marriage stuff. This has to be 100% legit romantic relationship
for a deeper purpose than just coming into the United States.
All right? And uh I'm not going to limit this. We're not going
to limit this for Americans cuz we want our Elon super babies,
right? We want Elon super babies. Elon obviously he's got more
than one uh woman here in his life and this could work with a
lady or whatever. I mean, it doesn't matter. We can be equal
opportunity. There's a female Elon out there. That can happen
too, right? But we're not limiting this to one because we want
all those American super babies in America. Once again, I think
most people will only do one. But hey, let's leave the
Elon Musk's dad was a pedophile.
I don't know. I I'm worried there's a genetic component there,
and I don't want that passed down into America. Okay, I say that
as a Canadian, but also somebody who knows that Elon has ties
to my country and could easily have kids here. Okay, let's get
those jeans. Let's stop calling them super babies. Let's call
them and waiting. Okay. Like we don't want that here. All right.
Get them out. Get them out. >> Adoption open for Americans
cuz they're American. Uh protect both Americans and foreigners,
male and female. Every gender, every person will be protected
>> Grimes is Canadian, right? What? Oh, she is gross.
Oh, that's really unfortunate.
Oh, she is sort of like the living embodiment of Vancouver, isn't
she?
Damn. Okay. >> Here. Okay. So this is something that's
going to protect everybody. Everybody will be safe. First of
all, at any time either party can terminate the visa. So if anybody
wants out of this, they can get out of this. The only thing >> I'll
be real, I don't know anything about Grimes. I just said all
of that for I the impression I get from her from like her Hassan
stream appearances and like the two tweets I've seen is she's
like an attention-seeking loser. But I think her music is also
really enjoyed. Like I think she's actually quite popular. Like
she's famous as an artist first, right? She wasn't like famous
as somebody who was a great thinker like who's even maybe not
even super hot. Was she Did she incorporate her looks into her
music very much? I feel like she didn't. She had an incredible
album. Okay. All right. Sorry. Let's focus on Let's focus on
legal mindset. Okay. I
I'm trying to think of like why why would there be I guess you
could make a visa. This is just like a green card system, right?
You meet somebody from out of the country, you bring them in.
Expediting it. I don't know why. Like that's all I'm looking
for here. I'm I'm ant I'm identifying it
for what it is. Okay. Just this is every like libertarian every
law tuber. Okay. They'll like say the government is totally broken
and then they'll propose the exact thing the government does
already more or less. They're like it would be really cool if
it worked like this and it's like actually that's exactly what
they try to do already. It's literally literally what they try
to do. >> Thing is hey if you're the one the foreigner
coming to us if you terminate this you do have to go home. You
do have to leave. You do have to go home. That's just the way
it is. I'm sorry. It sucks, but you got to go home, right? Within
two years, you have to have a child together. Now, I'm not saying
uh have a >> Oh [__] Is this not going right?
Oh, did I not I I didn't move this back. Oh [__]
Whoops. I didn't move this back. My bad. Oh, he's like going
through. Hold on. I can fix this.
Sorry. Todd Bronson was like, "Hey, is it do I have to like fix
something here for you?"
No. No, no, you don't. That should be not see-through. Okay.
Boom. There it is. There it is.
Uh oh, also Top Bronson, sometimes
when I use the Kermit, I have to use a magenta background, and
then the magenta background conflicts with some things. I should
just give you It's like magenta and then uh like the green screen
are the two colors that probably shouldn't be in the avatars
like too closely.
Yeah, I just had this I had this like two a >> marriage
because I believe a marriage and I'm a religious person, a Christian
specifically and I believe marriage is between you and God and
many people believe that as well. Right? It's a very common belief.
You do not necessarily need to go into the eyes of the state
to have a kid. Right? I get that. We're in a modern era. Things
are different and things are changing. Okay. But you got to prove
yourself to the country by having a child that literally gives
you something linking you to the country, a reason to stay there
and also a reason to stay with the partner because once again
at any time this is terminable. So you've got to stay with that
partner. Uh the foreign applicant, the foreign breeder can only
apply for one visa per lifetime. So they have to think carefully.
They cannot monkey branch. They cannot go to a different person.
They have to stay with the person that they applied with. This
ensures this is for a true romantic purpose and not for a scam.
And this needs to be heavily enforced by ICE agents. We're hiring
more ice agents. Maybe Pokemon can
dude. This is uh Oh, no. This is Oh, this is H1Bs. He's just
proposed H-1Bs.
Like, actually, technically, if you try to lead this person,
you get deported. Keep this person. We'll deport you.
>> Keep writing the code. Keep writing the code. Sing or
you're getting deported. Okay, you're back to Mumbai. Keep writing
the code >> again. So they are able to get enough agents
to actually enforce this. We need way more ICE agents. Uh foreign
breeder must be unmarried abroad. Uh so they've got to have no
husband, wife, whatever, whatever they are, they got to have
nobody abroad. So there's nothing abroad. and there's any form
of fraud is caused for immediate deportation and possible criminal
penalties. So, if they're lying about a husband or lying about
children, that's not going to work. The American host is not
financially responsible for any foreign dependent children. So,
if you have any children abroad, they are not responsible for
those. The foreigner has to be up to date on their stuff there.
If they're hiding those from you, if they're lying to you, that
could also be fraud, right? So, they better disclose to you all
their situation, whether they're, you know, secretly married
or whatever else. They better disclose all that stuff, right?
All that stuff better come out, right? Because otherwise, they're
going back to their country. Cap entry per year. So, first you're
going to want a pilot program, and then you're going to want
to increase it over time. You're going to want to do very in-depth
interviews to make sure these people are genuinely romantically
in love with each other, and make sure there's no security issues
like terrorism, which is what unfortunately happened in the issue
with the guardsman, uh, Miss Beckram, who passed away in, uh,
America very, very recently. We don't want anybody who's a terrorist
coming in, male or female. So, we need a very good security vetting
of both of these individuals. Uh, so, uh, Trump's already signed
off. I think he's got Melania here once again. Uh, he understands
the ability to go abroad, find somebody, and get married, breed,
have kids. I mean, this is something he knows about himself.
>> Did he go abroad or was he just at like some Sports
Illustrated event where there were models?
Also, Jesus Christ,
her cheekbones.
My god. >> Oh, so in my mind, he's already signed off.
And then you, this is a potential money printer. We've got The
Bachelor. The Bachelorette meets 90Day Fiance. These are all
wildly popular uh shows that make a bunch of money.
>> Wait, what? Why is this included? I thought this was
for love. Wait, what?
Oh, yeah. Wait, what? >> Guess what? The federal government
can run this and they can make some money off of this. Instead
of losing money, feds, you can actually make money and justify
yourself in your existence. Isn't that crazy? Wouldn't that be
good if we had this, you know, running and they were making money
and it paid for the administration. The administration paid for
itself. Wouldn't that be crazy? Well, we could do that. We got
Big Ed over here. So, we'll have that breeding version, right?
Absolutely hilarious.
Is he like, "Oh, dude. [laughter] Is he Is he proposing government
funded like Oh my god. It's like government fun. I was going
to say government funded media, which is fine, but I It's not
even just that. It's like
It's like if the government funded Ice Boseidon to do some Okay.
No, no, no. It's not statemandated GFS. It's like PBS Bachelor.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It's like PBS Bachelor or something. He's like,
"If you sign up, listen, we'll expedite your visa or whatever
even more. If you want to do the show, if you want to do the
show, we'll make that happen immediately." >> Great. Great
comedy, great stuff. It'd be fantastic. Uh then we got a pilot
program. I would like to nominate Asmin Golden Gran. Uh if you
from Five Hearts Under One Roof, the actress for Gran. Uh if
you haven't seen The Love between them, absolutely adorable.
I love it. So cute. So >> shipping Asmin Gold with some
totally plastic Korean woman, I guess. >> Finally got a
bit of free time now, huh?
>> Look at how tense your shoulders are.
>> Can you help me with my stance?
I think it's catcher, right? Like help her. It's catch, right?
Oh god, we got to make it happen between these two. Um, and see
what happens there. I've got a special Korean lady in my life
I'd think about for this, but we'll have to see whether she agrees
uh with me. Um, next guys, we've got
mindset. This is my Tik Tok. And then we've got legal.
>> Oh my goodness. We might have to go through the Caseyron
stuff, dude.
Apparently there's a Willie video. There's like a Willie video
on the Casey Tron thing, bro. Like, I I almost I understand Casey
Tron doesn't want to do it. Okay.
But like, oh man, I it sucks asking somebody to throw away their
dignity cuz maybe she already has. But why doesn't she just go
like, "I'm sorry, Ethan. I reallyed up. I shouldn't have messed
with you." Cuz like at this point, I do think like going after
her is totally psychotic. I do. I do. I understand that she's
like one of the worst like most offensive women that exists.
I understand how people hate it, okay? Or how people hate her,
but like holy.
Okay, just
don't take her house, okay? Don't take her house.
Like, she's like 40. Don't take her house. She doesn't really
get any stream views anymore. Don't take her house, dude. That's
so that's so
I'm sorry. Like, just let her opt out. Just let her be like,
I up. I wish he I wish he would have done it almost immediately.
Okay. Just gone like, "Hey, Ethan, I'm sorry." Not that Ethan
deserves it. Not that Ethan deserves an apology, but I'm I'm
just sitting here like, "Dude, could you I I hate seeing people
broken. I hate seeing people I hate broken. Like, there are people
I hate and seeing them like broken.
I It just bothers me, man. I I'm sorry. I don't even hate Caseyron,
but just like the the kind of people who want to like
who want to use their their their their money, their status,
their wealth to like try to break someone is
wild to me. Like you you have so many positive things you could
do. And honestly, like at this point, I think he's like done
the less. He's like given the lesson. If he just wanted to go,
okay, pay my legal fees so far and I'll I'm not even gonna take
anything. Just settle out of court, pay my legal fees, I'll let
it go. Right? Which already will be a lot of money. It's probably,
you know, a couple probably in the tens of thousands already,
I would imagine. Right. Just pay my legal fees and I'll [__]
it off. No good reason to hate her. Uh she will she's like annoying.
She's like Hassan in that she will totally deflect from her negative
actions, her negative like things she's done. Her She'll totally
deflect from them and pretend she did nothing wrong, which is
a little weird.
This might make you feel less empathetic.
No, no, no. She's I and I understand she's done things. I understand
that she made fun of Asmin goal for killing his mom. That was
totally psychotic. Yep. Yep.
And I understand how that can happen, but it's like she's opting
out. Listen, she's like [laughter] she is a who put her gun down.
Okay,
now I understand the thing that feels good is to her in the head.
All right, I get it. I understand to torture her to shoot her
in the head. But sometimes you go, "Oh, they they're admitting
they're wrong. They're like, that's why she has to do that, right?
She has to apologize and admit she was wrong. She has to like
actually confess for for something. And dude, you got to go.
You got you got to let the pride go and apologize and just be
like, I up. I was like, now I I can see all of this. And then
then everybody every single person who's going after her this
hard, if she could just come out and say, I up. I can see how
I was going after people and how that hurt people and I really
wish this could stop now.
Right. I then you can then you can call those people psychotic
if they keep going after her, right? But she I haven't seen it
yet. I haven't seen her like break and and like give up her pride
and just say, "I'm sorry. I've participated in the cycle. I really
up. I don't want to be a part of it anymore."
Right. Her gun was literally being attractive, though. Okay.
Well, I think Casey broke herself with her debilitating 20-year
weed habit. Uh yeah, sure. Hold on. This is I think we're done
with the as the sorry, the um legal mindset video. Azimold shows
receipt of the amount of harassment he has received from Casey
Tron over six years after she accused him of harassing >> So
this is the and he's like he's right. She said really really
vile things about him. I don't have any problem with Asold hating
her. It's the audiences who come along like there is nothing
to me wrong with Asminold absolutely despising Caseyron for the
things she said about him. Okay, that makes total sense to me.
That makes total sense. All right. But the audiences that come
into play here, it's like, okay, there are a lot of people who
will just like consistently make Casey Tron's life hell on the
internet now. And
and I feel some what do you call it? I feel like just some understanding
of that. So he can punch. You really think a single one of them?
Hold on. You really think a single one of them will stop going
after her? So he can punch, but she can't punch back. No, I I'm
telling you people will still go after her. But I'm saying they
look totally psychotic at that point. I'm saying more for like
me cuz right now I can always point to and and sometimes for
me personally I don't need people to break to like go okay I
don't need to do this anymore but other people do right other
people will never let it go and for asminold is particularly
rough because I think every single time Caseyron cries on stream
asminold literally prints like a couple hundred,000
so you need as gold to really rise above a lot
every time Caseyron cries on stream as gold gets the value of
her house precisely in dollars from YouTube revenue every single
time. Did you see Dioro getting backlash for defending Hassan
against the broth allegations and he molded about everyone calling
him a Hassan Tik Tok?
Uh yeah, Dioro's got it rough. Okay,
he's got it rough in that he's got like a critical audience on
both sides that he's he's basically only got people who watch
who are on either side like extremely in a extremely polarized
fashion. So, no matter what he says, he's uh he's kind of
me reaping me sewing. It's not really that. It's
uh how do I explain it?
It's kind of that, but it's not really that. He's he's got just
a really polarized audience. Anybody who used to watch him is
like upset with him. Anybody who does watch him will be upset
if he like takes us on side on anything.
And that's just how people engage with drama. People engage with
drama by finding the person who most aggressively takes It's
like politics, right? Who's the guy who's most insanely on my
side? Okay, I'm going to go watch that guy's stuff. Who's the
guy who says like, "I'm the ultimate victim. I am like my side,
ultimate victim, their side, ultimate evil." Who's the person
who will like dumb it down to that? And I guess Nick has engaged
in that quite a bit with Ethan Klein. So maybe he has maybe he
is sewing a little bit. Yeah. Not a lot of
everybody says that they're nuanced and then Nick does a little
nuance and his audience loses it in either direction.
Very goofy stuff. Okay, just very goofy stuff. All right, let's
give this a look. We'll see. I I don't want to defend Casey Trot
and then not look at the bad she said, but I remember this. I
remember saying she was totally psychotic for this. >> The
person who's complaining about me harassing her. >> Oh,
is this just her talking about Asminold? Oh, okay.
[laughter]
I don't think it's a good I understand why this hits for people
but it's like not even again
do we not all see what happens here that Azenold like by existing
and getting like a message about Caseyron his audience will go
after Caseyron if she posts it anywhere prominent he doesn't
have to talk back to her but she doesn't have people who with
her in the same way so she is the person posting right she's
the person posting
asoldold isn't but his audience is like asoldold does sort of
sanction things his audience does. If he didn't want his audience
to do this, he'd say, "Don't do this. I'll ban you from my communities
and stuff." Right? He could he could protect. Now, he doesn't
have to do that. He's not obligated to do that. But like she's
describing harassment from his community.
So,
it's or him and his community that he does a message and then,
you know, once he's like named her persona nongrada, his community
will go after her. Dude, it's uh I don't know. It like this doesn't
prove anything at all. I'm sorry. It doesn't. These are the amount
of times that she's tweeted about me and talked about me. Man,
how about that?
You guys thought it was over. No, it just didn't load. That's
funny. That's funny that it stopped to load. Okay, I like that.
That's funny. God, I hate that smug face he makes. I like that
smug face he makes. Okay, I like that. I got to
Man, I like it. Okay, I like it a lot. >> Oh, yeah. There
was too many of them. I think it's very funny. This guy's like
the perfect the I I feel about Asminold the way Kenny does about
food shops. Okay,
man. This guy like sucks in so many ways, but he is a good villain.
Okay, he is like if if we had to pick a villain for the like
the internet for for my part of the internet, he's a good villain.
Okay, he is a good villain. I like I like that this guy exists
because he like gives me some foil to like go off of all the
time. Okay. >> I wonder I >> And he's good at it.
He is good at it. >> I wonder how long it's going to go.
>> I do. I wonder how long it's going to go for. Let's
find out. It's 2023. There's no way it can go that much longer,
right? You're both oldest. Have streamed for a decade. More than
a decade. Yes, it can keep going. What do you mean,
bro? You You have disliked this person since like 2019, 2018.
Yeah, it's going to keep going past 2020. What did he say? 2021,
2019. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. This is Yeah, this is like the credits
for uh Oh, there we go. Okay, it's over now. Yeah, this is like
the credits for Concord.
It's unbelievable. So, you've been getting mad about me for 6
years
and you've been a victim.
Well,
now you actually are.
Too bad, huh? Oh, wow. A victim of your own stupidity from Casey
Tron. As Oh, the opposite for me from Asmin Gold.
This doesn't prove ah
gay gay to pretend this proves anything. >> The last
[laughter] Okay, that's funny. Just a top tweet,
the facial expressions. He got he got better at this, right?
He got better at using silence and just his facial expression.
I feel like even a year ago that when I started covering him
for his political takes, when he's starting to become political,
I feel like he didn't do this. I feel like he's gotten so much
better at it. Like explicitly clip farming. Like I would believe
you if you told me if somebody came out and there's like a you
know a whole like whistleblower and they're like Asenold actually
has a writer room with like 40 people and not just a writer room
he's got like a whole business and not only does he have that
business but
he hires like psychologists like statistical like analysts like
data analysts and he figures out like what makes other people
like mechanically and he will figure all that stuff out and integrate
it into his stream cuz I swear to God he didn't do this stuff
and now he's like started doing it all the time. He just does
like these smug faces, these big poses all the time. Like he's
straight up posing for clips all the time. It's like his he's
like got this specific cadence. If if you told me that yeah,
he basically had a whole team. It was all like meticulously engineered.
Wouldn't shock me
at all. >> This time I trailer park Lex Luthther. >> Exactly.
I I called her fat and that she smelled bad.
And this is something reasonable.
This is also something reasonable. Oh. Oh, no. No. This is her
being annoying. >> He knows what he's doing. Even going
back to intentionally failing at games to increase chat engagement.
I could see that. Yeah, I could see that. Did I miss Zena? No,
no, no. We're going to get to it right away. We're We're right
there. We're like, >> you want to make So, this is it.
End of this segment. Anyway, Asminold,
the true victim of harassment from Casey Trron. Okay. Obviously.
Obviously. All right. What were we going to do now? We finished.
Oh, I didn't even get into my price video. Well, we might save
this.
We might do this another time because we do want to get to the
Zena content. And not only that, but I wanted to cover these
uh these substance tweets.
Oh, did I close the last substance tweet? Hold on. I did want
to get to one of these tweets that I quote tweeted. Ah, yes.
Yes. So,
uh This is just very funny. Okay, dude. Yikes. Lack of logic
at good logic reminds Destiny at the omni liberal that he and
Trump share a perverse interest of teenage girls. Okay, so this
is this is funny. This is from some debate like last night or
something. All right,
this isn't the only funny part about this. Okay, >> so
next time being something anything other than a than a Trump
come filled water balloon and maybe we can have a real conversation
about things. >> All right.
Oh mention.
Boom. There it is again. Bro, how is every clip of this guy him
mentioning? How? It's literally just all the time. How is he
this obsessed with it? It's >> So, you see this even now
as I'm walking out, you still have to just a little bit of trolling.
It's trolling. We're just trolling. It's trolling. Lol. >> That's
fine. No, that's that's fine. But it's LOL. >> It's not
It's not actually showing anything other than that you're able
to appeal to 17year-olds. >> Oh, is that what Donald Trump
does? Or you mean 17y old? I don't know. Maybe was it 15 or 14?
I remember. Maybe I was going to say maybe appealing to 15, 17
year olds is right your thing. Maybe that's your thing, Destiny.
>> Good logic really fumbled this kind of
>> he tried to make it like deniable almost.
He tried to like he he tried to make it deniable and [clears throat]
he really does it.
Okay, hold on. I was watching a second. >> It's not It's
not actually showing anything other than that you're able to
appeal to 17-year-olds. Oh, is that what Donald Trump does? Or
you mean 17? I don't know. Maybe was it 15 or 14? I don't remember.
Maybe I was going to say maybe appealing to 15
is your thing. Maybe that's your thing, Destiny. Like I wonder
this makes me think I wonder if Wick made these people agree
not to bring this up to come on this stream or something cuz
I would imagine that's like the first thing people bring up if
they're talking to Destiny in most places. Yeah. Wait until Destiny
hits good logic with the undefeable rejoinder. Okay. Of actually
that was a minor so me getting their videos their videos that
didn't count. That's not holding child because that minor was
actually I was talking to the trafficker not the minor directly.
So retaining the child was okay. Is your is your thing? >> I
don't know. >> The difference is I don't lose my civil
cases like Trump lost his that one woman. Was it Eugene Carol?
But we don't
>> Eugene is not a woman's name. >> Uh Eugene Carol.
But I think I make that mistake. So hard to hard to judge on
that one. Did he really just say though the difference between
me and Donald Trump is I don't lose my civil cases?
Yes, Donald Trump and I do both like biters. Donald Trump and
I both violate consent. The main difference is I win my civil
cases. One, you didn't win your civil case. Two, can't you think
of a better difference? I hope you could think of a better difference.
I One would hope, one would really hope, pray you could come
up with something better.
He's basically saying the difference is he got away with it.
Yeah, that's basically what he's saying. Yes,
but he also didn't get away with it yet. Now, do we expect Pixie's
case to come out and be like totally successful? Not
Nope. But
uh he hasn't lost yet. I guess he says I win my civil cases.
He has not won yet.
just one of those things where it's like he is he knocking on
wood or cuz he said cases there. Is he knocking? Is he knocking?
Is he wishing for something? I don't know. Like those four cases,
right? We don't like those right now. >> I thank you all
for Yeah. I thank you all for joining me. It was great. >> I
do appreciate I I really want to say thank you for staying. I
do appreciate that. So, thank you. >> Take care, Wick.
Have a great night. >> Oh, some other guy like left this
panel, like ran off this panel or something. >> I don't
know who the other guy was. Yes. Oh, that's what I actually wanted
to look at here. Substance was like,
you tweet this and then good logic because substance is lack
of logic. Good logic. So, like we're we're not conservatives,
right? Well, substance isn't. I'm not really anymore either.
Okay. But good logic response likely went over your head that
I was referencing Destiny's publicly murky history with women.
I suppose a lot goes over your head, dude. You should like It's
like, no, no, that didn't go over his head. That's literally
that's literally exactly that's the wavelength he's operating
on precisely. Um, I don't know if you know this, but Destiny
has a civil case involving like Congress with a minor. Okay,
he's got a civil case on this. It's like, "Oh, trust me. Substance
knows. Substance knows. He knows. He knows. He knows. He knows.
He knows. He knows."
Uh.
Oh. What is this? The food slops effect. DG viewers/ chatters
are making it clear that they can no longer stomach rogue lollycon
streamer at not food shops having any direct association with
their community.
Oh, wait. That's only because now it seems like they now they
feel confident about the civil case, right?
When when food chops was the only person on YouTube who' defend
Destiny, they loved her. It's almost like this stuff isn't consistent
at all. It's almost like they were just using her at the time
because only a would defend Destiny.
Crazy. I'm sure, trust me, I'm sure food shops built like a really
solid community based on her analysis alone and nothing else.
Like I I'm guessing that's what really happened, right? She probably
built like a very consistent community who will show up and engage
with her ideas, her thoughts, and not just some not just, you
know, the people who show up to watch her defend Destiny. I'm
sure I'm positive that happened, guys. That definitely happened.
Uh, you can be a person, but stop openly bragging about it and
trying to normalize it. Oh, sorry. This is bottom to top. She
literally spoke about wanting to children. Lol W. Like, have
some shame about it. Freak. This guy definitely still watches
the streams, by the way. 100%. 100%. You You sound like a caricature.
Oh, I wonder what Pickle What was Pickles Nathan saying back
to this guy.
XC can't even vote. You [__] [__] He's
probably a liberal in Canada. She spoke about how she would fantasize
about [__] actual children. I ain't going to find
the clip. Maybe they know. Maybe they just know. You can be a
person but stop openly bragging about it. Okay.
Is this bottom to top again? Bottom to top. Boot chops is a convicted
rap because she raped the six. This is not true.
Okay. Listen,
listen. If you told me, if we found that out, I wouldn't be totally
shocked, but there is no evidence that that is the case. Okay.
Zero. Zero.
Legal mindset. Food shops cross over
I don't know, bro. I'm just waiting.
Do you think Dev can get food shops on Adam and Sitch?
You think Adam and Sitch will want to engage with food shops?
Bro, I food chops is like the is like the perfect litmus test.
Like if you're cool with this person, if you pretend they have
like good ideas when they can't defend anything they say.
H just the perfect litmus test. You like know who the disingenuous
people are automatically. Good stuff. Let's keep looking. Food
shops didn't exist. Chat would be normal right now. Mr. Girl
was a just like food shops. You guys are making me hate food
shops. Please stop. Imagine watching food shops. Food shops keep
yourself. Food shops don't interact with DGs.
Hop on the debate queen arrive.
Go watch some you den.
Here's one thing though. No one would be talking about this except
people trying to get food shops
uh to think about girl
freak. Okay.
Do you think Dev has enough pull with Adam and Sitch that they
would lend their show to his chasing? Yes, if he really wanted
to. But I'm just saying like who is she going to network with
if she's out of the DG orbit? I just want to point out that as
long as she was covering Destiny's case positively, nobody in
that DG orbit had any problem with her being there. Okay, they
weren't going to do anything. They barely said anything. Conor
is the one person who said something. It was basically like,
hey, don't hang out with that. And then I think he also was like,
"But her dreamalk a logging content is really
Name one opinion you appreciate from that. Name one thing that's
interesting. Name anything." It's literally the sad thing is
for Connor saying like, "Oh, her J- SOG Alogging content is really
funny." I know you didn't watch it for one thing. Okay, I know
you didn't watch
You're just providing cover for a You're literally just helping
a Which is truly shocking giving how he chastised both Queenman
and Chudlo Logic for doing precisely that with food chops in
the first place. Actually, I'm not sure they're friends anymore.
Oh, Connor and Destiny selling a sloth. No, you're wrong. They
I thought that too and then they went shooting like two days
later or some Are you talking about somebody else? Ridiculous
cuz Destiny is huge. Could completely ignore Jay talk and be
fine but instead he uses Well, yeah. It's like the the actual
doxing stuff as well.
I have to get on that right now. Right. Like right now. Get on
the um
just going to write up a a couple quick documents about that.
The doxing threats and stuff are very goofy. Okay. It's very
very goofy. Oh, this is the other thing we have to go over possibly
is the Rose Lo split I've heard is not Rose. The Grace Thorp
lopplit has been catastrophic from what I understand. Oh, wait.
Oh, de I see what you're saying. SFO and Sitchin Adam. Gotcha.
Gotcha.
Anyway, I just thought it was very funny that Substance clearly
is aware of Desessie's case, clearly aware of the allegations
against him, but
absolutely not aware. Okay.
Uggh, she still exists. The food shops
Yeah. Oh, Grace Thorp. God, my delay on my chat is so brutal
right now. I don't know how to fix it. Anyway,